are you surprised
because you know in in
in law
if you do something that they're not
happy with they'll take your license
away from you are you surprised that
they haven't tried to take your license
to practice as a doctor away from you
i practice at the highest quality of
medicine possible
i am fully board certified and
re-certified in internal medicine
in cardiology
i
am
very clear on
my interpretations of the data and my
reductions to clinical practice
and if anybody
wants to review my license my answer is
bring it on because i want to review the
information with them
and we'll ask which paper which citation
do they want to review first because we
have a lot to go over dr mccullough
is it fair to say that you are
controversial no
you're not
um
other people would disagree my question
to you is
were you controversial or did people
look at you as being controversial prior
to covet no i've never been
controversial
what is
getting people uncomfortable is the
truth
and you mentioned
that i'm effectively kryptonite to
youtube and google
into any of these other social media why
because it's the truth and they melt
away from it in fear if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you